Pues los líderes de Marruecos y de
España firmaron una veintena de textos
que van tocan temas muy variados como el
manejo del agua las energías renovables
o la educación Pero sin duda los más
importantes son de carácter económico
Como por ejemplo un acuerdo de 800
millones de euros para que empresarios
españoles inviertan en Marruecos también
programas de migración circular para que
jóvenes marroquíes y específicamente
dirigido a los jóvenes puedan ir a
trabajar temporalmente a suelo español
además de la normalización progresiva
del paso de personas y de mercancías a
través de ceuta y melilla esas dos
ciudades autónomas españolas que están
en continente africano para asegurar el
cumplimiento de toda esta veintena de
acuerdo se va a crear un mecanismo de
seguimiento Eso sí en la declaración
final de este de esta Cumbre el
presidente del gobierno español Pedro
Sánchez ha dicho y cito textualmente que
ambos países eludirán todo aquello que
saben que ofende a la otra parte algo
que da mucho pie a la interpretación
pero que se ASUME que se refiere a temas
como el Sáhara occidental o la soberanía
de precisamente estas dos ciudades que
mencionaba antes ciudades autónomas
españolas ceuta y melilla que están en
territorio africano